why am i at this point and how the hell
has someone died
under my watch you can't even go and
kill yourself you can't even go hurt
yourself
you're [ __ ] useless and i'm beneath
the surface and you can hear the thumps
overhead like
and i turned around and looked at vice
and he went [ __ ] run
now
[Music]
wow this is the most gripping inspiring
twisting conversation i've
ever had on this podcast ever if you're
squeamish i'm gonna have to ask you to
prepare
but even if you are i'm begging you to
follow this story
my guest grew up in a broken home one
plagued with domestic violence with
abuse with heartbreak and he moved to
five six seven different schools as he
stumbled through his childhood
trying to find his way trying to find
out who he was and then stumbled through
his adolescence looking for purpose in
life
and he was met with rejection with pain
with confusion with barriers
and as he spiraled into daily drug abuse
into addiction
and into purposelessness a job that he
hoped would give him that sense of
purpose
ended in a manslaughter case and this
tragedy only caused him to spiral
further
and as he reached the depths of his
despair he made that decision one day
that he was going to leave his house
go for a drive and end his life for
whatever reason
and thankfully he didn't go through with
it and by fate or luck or faith or
whatever you want to call it whatever
you believe
a short youtube advert that popped up
one day out of the blue would be the
catalyst for him to pull himself out of
his darkest
most desperate moment to give up drugs
to overcome his mental challenges to
brush himself off
and to pursue his childhood dreams he
went from suicidal drug addict to elite
commando
developing what he calls the commando
mindset a mindset and a set of values
that you can learn
but his story doesn't stop there his
time as a commando is riddled with
graphic violence with
heartbreak with being injured by the
taliban while at war
he'll describe the moments after he was
blown up and turning around and seeing
his friends laying there behind him in
pieces
and losing some of those friends being
discharged from the military because of
his injury
grappling with ptsd finding comfort in
alcohol and addiction again
getting himself in trouble with the law
finding himself in court
facing four years in prison and then
rebuilding himself once again
launching an incredible coaching company
and working with elite performers
harry kane gareth southgate and the
whole england team before they went off
to the world cup
and then the pandemic comes and his
coaching business collapses
but in typical ben williams fashion
adversity doesn't dictate his outcome
thanks to the values ingrained in his
commando mindset
he bounces back to launch an incredible
tech company what a wild
emotional gripping ride you're about to
go on honestly congratulations for
choosing to listen to this episode
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire of a ceo
i hope nobody is listening but if you
are then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
ben from doing this podcast over the
last couple of years one of the things
that i've
been reminded of and an idea that's been
reinforced in my mind
is how important all of our childhoods
are
in influencing what we then become and i
studied childhood psychology between the
age of like 16 and 18
and it blew my mind to understand
especially in those early years
how that sort of fundamentally shapes
who we then become as adults and it's
and it's in some respects often quite
hard to shake right um you know that old
adage of not being able to teach a new
dog new tricks because we're so we learn
most of our behaviors when we're young
so my first question for you is tell me
about your childhood
tell me about that experience how did
that shape you
yeah my um my parents had quite a rough
divorce when i was around
i think six seven years old um
and i never speak about that divorce i
never go into detail
never talk about what it was but it
wasn't nice
and we sort of didn't see dad for a
while
and then the mortgage wasn't paid and
mom had to take everything on
and we had to move and we went from this
lovely house
to a very small house on a sort of
council estate
and i think at that age i didn't
really see it too much i just it was
part of the journey it was part of the
process i didn't
recognize her problems i didn't
recognize what was happening it was just
our dad's gone we're probably young
enough to just get on with
this and it's funny because my kids are
the age now
and i think about what are they
processing now what they're going
through how they seeing this what do
they see every angle like
um and then i think as i got a little
bit older and i began to
understand their separation a bit more
and how it was
not a clean break
it i felt like i was a young child who
almost wanted to protect his
mum i had my younger brother that i
thought i wanted to
or knew i wanted to look after and
protect
and then she found a boyfriend who
wasn't a father figure
and i hope you wouldn't mind me saying
that as well he was just
there in the background so when you said
it wasn't a clean break
[Music]
you mean there was domestic violence
issues or there was
it was uh it was an aggravated
separation that's pretty much as far as
i'll go on it
um but we witness things
we witness things and i think that stays
with you quite
clearly in your mind as you move through
and when we go
and move and transition into this kind
of new phase of our life in a new house
with a new
man in the house who wasn't really
acting up as dad
it was probably the most problematic
area to be
mum's dad and mum um
and you can actually fall out with mum
because she's trying to be dad
and vice versa as well and i have
probably the closest relationship in my
entire family is with my mum
because i recognise everything she's
been through
and she's an extremely resilient
lady who's got herself to where she is
today
but it is true and i'm listening to your
podcast and
looking back on my own journey you see
every single little thing begins to
affect you i think
later down the line rather than what
you're going through at that moment it's
all about that process and
i don't think that processing happens
very well when you're a child
as i just said it's kind of next phase
next phase next phase
you know then all of a sudden six seven
schools later
um and you don't fit in and you know i'm
not the broken wing story
if you don't if you come to school and
you don't know anyone you're the kid
they're gonna pick on
so that was part of the experience and
then
then you find your feet a little bit in
the system like my sort of final school
that was kind of my make or break moment
and i think i went more towards break
you said that when you're young you
don't really know what things mean
so you're kind of experiencing them but
you're not like consciously processing
them yeah
but they are still sitting with you and
having an impact on your world view
then they're telling you what a
relationship looks like and
what a relationship with you know your
siblings or someone else or
authority looks like for example but you
don't have that time to process it and i
think
as is the case in my life i like didn't
process a lot of this stuff until i was
like
29 or like 28 or whatever yeah um
and i guess that's the same for you
right it just feels normal
i think if you've not experienced
anything before what you then go through
feels normal
um well this must be reality this must
be how we do things
and then you just kind of crack on and i
think actually it was during my
military career and then been sort of
immersed in
what that throws at you that i kind of
describe it as like
almost the eddie stabard lorry that
you're just putting things in along the
way
every now and then you just stop and put
things in and then you're just traveling
at high speed and then
something will happen and you bang the
brakes on and then everything comes
flying forward
and that's what i kind of found over the
sort of my mid-20s
was why am i thinking of this again why
is this coming back what's this all
about and
trying to work out a way of beginning to
process what i should have processed
years ago
talks about six or seven schools um so
you
you were expelled or you were moving no
we moved a lot all right yeah we moved a
lot so we moved
from guildford and then up to beds area
and went to some schools in bucks and it
was just house to house
so we moved from school to school
which is difficult for a kid and i found
i found myself leaning more towards
listening to certain music types such as
heavy metal
very heavy metal actually and dressing
with it
and i think back then you know early
naughties is
oh there's there's a kid in the corner
with the black nail varnish on the spiky
hair and the dog color and he's new
let's throw exit him oh wow um
so i suppose maybe i didn't help myself
as well but
that was just it was a real strange one
because that's what i was into that's
i still like that stuff now um
yeah i felt like i wasn't accepted for
liking what i liked you know that's how
i kind of
didn't fit in for a while at school
and is that is that a coping mechanism
was was the music a coping mechanism was
was being different in school or
whatever it's some form of a coping
mechanism
because heavy heavy metal is pretty
emotional
sometimes i think it is uh
i think it does become a coping
mechanism
[Music]
i but i found it was the start of things
it was the start of escape
and it started with metal and then it
moved to more
sinister things such as drugs and at one
age
so i started smoking weed around 12.
um um
you know i tried weed before i tried
cigarette
weed got me with people i always wanted
to be with
or thought i always wanted to be with
and all of a sudden i was
smoking with the cool kids and oh this
is all right you know
i'm finally fitting in but it's only
because you're all
using weed and you're all focusing on
this one thing that your togetherness is
your little unit um
but then yeah i think drugs took a
little bit more of a hold of me than i
expected it to
and it was weed for several years and it
just got more and more weed
until i started to progress into my late
teens where i start to pick up on other
things which
is when it all gets a bit cloudier
going into the clouds what age did you
did you start
experimenting or using other drugs so
i think just to give you even more of an
insight of
what i was thinking is i think because
what happened between my parents
and then not really having a father
figure when we moved
i actually began this sort of hatred
towards males
um i just didn't like him i just
it seemed like it was the guys at school
who would pick and then i didn't have
father figure and it was
am i the male who where is the male here
and i just began this almost sort of
disliking to to males when i started at
school i started to have anger
management around 16
and then i i was going to ditch
everything at school i wanted to
join the marines and leave and my mum
god bless her was no you've got to stay
on the path you're on do you relate
do your a-levels and then move on and
then if you fancy doing it do it then
and that then left me quite bitter
because i was like i want to go and do
this this is my destiny i'm going to go
and join the military
and that sort of no from her was that
moment where i was like
well [ __ ] you i want to do what i want
but i still stayed in school and it was
like what's the next best
option i don't know why becoming a
bouncer suddenly becomes the next best
option
but i wanted to fit in and i wanted to
live
a more macho alpha male lifestyle and i
thought that was going to throw myself
in the deep end and become a bouncer
and so i managed to get my sia license
so prepped for my sie license which is
the badge you got to have as a bouncer
when i was about 17 and a half the
moment i turned 18
i was on the door and very quickly
learned what the real world was all
about
and it didn't go very smoothly for me in
the first instance whatsoever
so to try and skip
my almost youthful growth i started
injecting steroids
i started on started taking steroids
orally and then moved on to injecting
and then bulked up
and got angrier and a bit more difficult
to be around
you talked about wanting to be a bouncer
because it would
make you feel like an alpha male or
whatever um
and it would make you feel and why why
did i'm really like intrigued by that
i thought where did the desire come from
to be
considered an alpha male
whether in your own mind or to external
to other people so
i think part of it is the fitting in is
why can't you fit in
around that time you know lock stock was
quite old but
snatch and certain other films were out
which
they were quite they're almost in the
limelight it seemed like that way a life
seemed to be normal
uh not normal but what you should aspire
to be
like uh aspirational the aspirational
like gangster
um and i watched a bit too much of that
you know i read
lenny mclean's book and roy shaw's book
and thought oh you've got to be hard to
fit in in this world
but i take to take you that moment where
as basically mum said no you're not
joining in the marines until you're 18
or at least
do your a-levels when we did sort of
begin to have every fortnight weekend
with dad again
the marines museum is somewhere where he
used to take us
we also went to the parachute regiment
and uh to the imperial war museum here
used to just take us around these
military museums for some reason
i remember being a young sort of
nine-year-old in inata or as well
looking at these pictures of these
really incredible people i thought
because this is what inspired me
i thought i want to be a marine and you
know as back as sort of nine years old
10 years old
and then when it's kind of many years
later when you suddenly almost pluck up
the courage to be like let's do this
it's a no it turns you quite bitter
and quite angry and why not this is what
i've always wanted to do and it and it
does feel like that someone
suddenly puts a blocker in the way of
what you've always wanted to do
your sense of purpose yeah that can that
can make you
um think in rather negative ways and i
that for me was when it was what else
can i do this
is it this out is it this alpha male
thing you know that's is that what a
marine is is what's the closest to that
then
and where can i fit in and that's kind
of what led me to the path of
i'll go where everyone seems to respect
you know
i'm not going to sneak into the
nightclubs like we used to do by putting
our
socks over our trainers at 17 to get in
i'm going to work on it and those kids
that have always taken the mick
those kids that have always thrown the
odd thing at me
are going to respect me and there i was
18 years old on the door
two questions the first is
what did your dad do professionally and
was your desire to be
macho in any way influenced by
um wanting to also be accepted by him at
all
i would want to say yes but i think i'll
say
no i
i don't know where it came from
um i don't know where it came from and
my second point was
there is a stigma in society that
bounces
have power complexes and what you've
described there sounds like a power
complex
yeah and it's this thinking that
mum was dad and there was no other male
in the house apart from her boyfriend
who didn't really
really be dad to us so do i need to be
dad do i need to be the alpha here
and the the older i got and the more i
was on the on the door
and the bigger i was getting um
and i was working five nights a week you
know
this was my full-time job and you were
getting feedback and validation from
yeah
women yeah and you know you get into the
you get into the fights you
you get better at it you get more
switched onto it you get more aggressive
with it
and all of a sudden that validation
comes in you think yeah well maybe this
is my purpose maybe i am supposed to be
here um
and you don't see the animal you're
becoming
even at that age you can be 20 years on
a door or you can
you can do it within a couple of years
if you start doing it every night and
becoming
almost laser focused on being there for
the violence
you're you're an animal it's like the
frog in the frying pan gradually being
yeah cooked it doesn't really it's a
good way of putting it yeah i i it's
particularly intriguing to me i've
actually never talked about this but one
of the people closest to me in the world
followed
almost an identical path and they went
through school
i i think in my view lacking validation
probably
in the top four people closest to me in
my life lacking this validation they
then
started using steroids at 18 17 18 years
old i found the steroids in their drawer
and then they went and became a bouncer
and they were doing it for
they told me for the attention from
girls on one hand but then also
because i think it did something for
their self-esteem and this person is
the single smartest person i know in the
world but being getting that validation
from being a tough guy on a door
and injecting steroids and going to the
gym and eventually he even started doing
some fighting like ufc fighting stuff
i think was um filling a hole in your
story though the
i read about an incident when you were a
bouncer that kind of changed everything
for you
yeah i remember um we had a neighbor
a little irish lady she's lovely she's
still with us she's still with us and uh
i think she knew the underworld better
than i did from where she was from
and i remember saying she said to me she
literally sat me down she not when she
found out i was joining
i was gonna work on the door um
she came and knocked on the house and
sat me down no one was in as well and
she was like you don't know what you're
getting yourself into
i was like i do know and strangely as a
young male
and you may have experienced this
yourself when someone says you can't do
something or you don't know what you're
doing
you're very quickly like i know exactly
what i'm doing i've watched all the
films i've read all the books i know how
to do a
some sort of kick i'll be fine and she's
like you don't know what you're getting
yourself into
okay so she was right
um there was an incident which happened
uh at one of the nightclubs in milton
keynes where
it was around 3 am and i was leaving
the venue as literally i was signing off
at 3 and the rest of the team of signing
off at 3 30.
and i was literally about to hand my
radio in
and there was just like this massive
screen down the range and we had a door
team i think of around
15. it was a big night club and it was
still pretty packed for this time
and yeah there was just this sort of
scream down the radio
and then you heard black black and that
was like
so you had code red which was like it's
kicked off code black is like we've lost
control
and you just kept hearing black black
down the down the mic
and i was with a friend of mine uh
another one of the doormen
and we were literally like what should
we do and just chuck the radios and run
to where it was and we ran down the fire
exit
it's in the escape builder i don't know
if you know the escape building in
milton keynes it's like it's just like a
maze you go through one exit and you're
just in a maze of concrete tunnels and
we were running
down the stairs and then sort of round
the corner and as we were running
towards coming in the back of this
part of the nightclub the doors just
bomb burst open
and everyone just fell through it was
like a dam of bouncers and people
scrapping
and it was just carnage there was just
people fighting all over the place who
couldn't even work out what was going on
um and then i recognized this massive
guy
who early that evening had just been a
pain and he gave me a massive kiss on
the lips and everything and like ruffled
my hair
when i had some um and was really
patronizing towards me and
and just he put me in my place that's
what he was doing
and they were fighting and it was
inevitable they were going to kick off
on this evening
and they did and i just remember seeing
like his arm dangling as
they were trying to force him to the
ground there was about three of the
other lads on them big guys
and then there was brother and then two
of the people fighting in this
this area of the team i just grabbed his
arm and he was just like
flailing me around and we i was just
slapping into the wall and then back on
and then we all hit the floor and there
was this
almost like crunch sound but no one
thought anything of it because he just
he went almost even stronger and i just
had this arm
i was lying there thinking this is he's
really trying to get up here this is
going to get out of control and you
could hear his brother screaming down
the corridor who's
a big lad himself um and we're probably
on the floor
probably about a minute trying to subdue
him you know calm down calm down
um and his face was facing back across
me
and it was just staring at the wall and
then i noticed some sort of pulling
underneath his head and uh it just
didn't look right the blood
itself was not a nosebleed it was
purpley
and i just said said to one of the lads
was like
i don't [ __ ] think he's well and
everyone literally just
massive breath came off him and he was
still lying there didn't get up
and then one of the bouncers was a
fireman
and i was like roll him over and then
began
trying to resuscitate him but to no veil
and he'd passed away there and there on
spot
remember standing there watching it all
unfold
suddenly going from this big alpha male
we're here to fight to
what the [ __ ] has just happened and then
they closed the club
and they nicked everyone and then we
were on man
or charged for about a year as they
tried to determine what happened
um he'd lost his life you know
as a man had come into a nightclub
whether he was a pain or not had lost
his life and worse than that
uh five kids had lost her dad
through an act of violence through
actually no one's fault
he fell and the way everyone landed on
him unfortunately broke a bone in his
neck which
caused him to go away and it was um it
was put down as
an accidental death there was no malice
in it there's
guys trying to defend themselves and and
the court recognized that and
i'm glad of that as well because
things like that don't always get
recognized and people all
do get in trouble for defending
themselves
um but for me it was a serious point in
my life where i thought
wow we're not in deep here
we're [ __ ] way past deep
um which became quite a hard thing to
deal with
and then you lose your job and by that
point i was already using cocaine and
steroids and
you're trying to keep up this addiction
and all of a sudden becomes an escape
and then you can't afford the steroids
you see yourself get skinnier and it's
what do i need to do i just i'll just do
more i just need more coke but cokes are
expensive and smoking more and more weed
and i just became extremely lost you
know i was uh
i was cleaning school toilets at one
point because
that was the only job i could get was to
be a cleaner and
for me i felt like i was very much
lying on rock bottom
you lose your sense of purpose at that
point right like you lose your sense of
orientation and
this i've you know in writing my book
and doing tons of studying over the last
two years i've really grown to
understand the importance of
especially men having a sense of purpose
and orientation
and as i did some reading about why the
life expectancy has dropped over the
last two years in the uk and the us i
think i've mentioned this before
the data suggests that it's because of
opioid addiction and then you say why
are people getting more addicted to
opioids
and the data suggests because men
specifically
are losing their sense of purpose and i
think jordan peterson's the one that
says there's a purposelessness epidemic
sweeping the world which is why the life
expectancy has started to decline
and it sounds exactly like that when i
when i read that in your story and as
you've said it then
sounds like one of the the worst things
that can happen to someone
a man or a woman is they lose their
sense of
as i say in my book their sense of like
chaos because that chaos and that
having stuff to strive for and aim for
seems to be our act our stability
um how bad did it get for you at that
time in terms of drug use and
and um your mindset
so i've written about it quite openly in
my book
um i was using it on tuesday mornings
you know in my mom's spare bedroom using
coke
right um and it got really bad
it got really bad to sort daily use
always that was it that was all that the
focus of the day
did like get cleaning work done or or if
i wasn't doing that just like oh soon my
mate
i literally had two mates which i did it
with and i'd just wait for him to finish
work and then we'd go and pick up and
then we go and see my course until
midnight just sat there just looking at
the stars
thinking it's a chill sesh really just
[ __ ] wasting my time
um and it was on one of those very
lonely days where i just sort of thought
i don't even know who i am and actually
i have a girlfriend at the time who's
now my wife
you want to meet a resilient woman my
wife has put up with me for so many
years
i've got a lovely family
and yet here i am sat with like half
pulled blinds
[ __ ] everywhere in my room no purpose
don't know where i'm going in life
taking drugs why like i'm from a nice
background
why am i at this point and how the hell
has someone died
under my watch how's this even happened
and for me that kind of was
a moment of obviously give up
so i took the i took the courser which i
shared with my brother
and i just went for a drive and i had it
in my head this sort of ambition that i
was just going to go and drive off
something or drive into something or
go and do something stupid
and uh try and escape what i thought was
this
internal pain it never happened it never
prevailed i never
did it i actually ended up back at home
after
losing track of time sat there
feeling sorry for myself oh you can't
even do that you can't even go and kill
yourself you can't even go hurt yourself
you're all [ __ ] useless
um which lo and behold is when i
sort of flicked on youtube the old
clunky version
and that advert appeared and i thought i
don't know if it's fate
i don't know if this is some sort of
sign from
above as the advert for the royal
marines
yeah and it just came up it was an old
advert
and it was just there just appeared as
part one of the videos that i should
watch
and it was a young lad and i reckon he
must have been about the age i was at
the time i
sort of 1920 i think it was at a time
still quite
loose on my time into that one and he
goes he's going through the endurance
course which is one of the commando
tests and one of the four commando tests
and the endurance course is
a two mile bogs tunnels
um just just just a muddy hell
that's the kind of way of crazy muddy
hell yeah and then a four mile run back
to camp
and to get to that point you have to
have done the 32 weeks of training
and that's the first test and i remember
watching it and
and he's running through wood wood
breeze on where it is would be common
he's running the stops and said would
you stop here
and then it goes again and it goes
through the tunnel would you stop here
and then they have this obstacle in
there called the sheep dip and the sheep
dip's about three meters long
and it's fully submerged and you have no
control what happens is
um someone will put you under they'll
force you through and then someone else
is the other side and they have to pull
you out you can't swim you just go
through like a torpedo and it's a bit
dramatic but this kid goes under the
water and gets his trousers stuck
on some jagged bit of metal and he's
like hanging out for breath
and then it's going it freezes would you
stop here
and then it freezes again and it does it
again does it like two or three times
and then it says if yes don't even
bother filling out the form
and then the next cut scene is him with
his green beret
at night on uh a speedboat
offshore raiding craft just going along
no music just this weird sort of tone it
was like
and then it goes 99.99
need not apply and that for me took me
back
to that young child in the royal marines
museum in portsmouth
who was looking at the pictures of old
guys of moustaches in the falklands and
the early iraq's
people who had become something
and i thought what else have i got to
lose what else
have i got to lose here than to just go
and do it
and that week was a turning point
so you applied yeah i can tell how much
that particular video
influenced you because you can describe
it i mean it must have been decades
right since you said yeah and you can
describe it in such graphic detail i
still watch it now oh really i still
watch it now only because it just
it reminds me of that sort of transition
in my life that
courage you know i always thought that i
had a lot of courage i think
a lot of men do they what is courage to
us
what what is courage and it
was something that i thought
i could establish or find on the door or
in like a violent world and be that
alpha male
where actually courage now i look back
over my years i look back and think
courage was the ability to go downstairs
you know after sitting there for hours
shall i shine
shall i not i'm going mom
you know you said no thinking of doing
it
and she went thank [ __ ] for that because
i've done my a levels and i think she'd
grown tired of me
yeah yeah and i was like what and it was
like this just acknowledgement like yes
please go and do that because we can see
what's happening here and you're ruining
your life and you're only just about
realizing it
and i was like last to the party and
realizing i was the one ruining my life
and the other hard part was you know my
girlfriend had been with some for some
time
[Music]
who had been through all of this up to
this point i'm now leaving her to go on
this journey
and become a royal marine and i think
that was for me the hardest part to
build that courage up and say
can i go and do this and she was like
yeah i support you with whatever you
want to go and do
and that was it it was literally i
described in my book like a couple of
days later
i literally just threw i had a pack of
coke in the house and just threw it
in the um in the toilet and flushed it
and didn't flush
i was like that was dramatic because i
thought
admittedly i kept smoking weed for a
little bit because it was my progression
off everything
but uh you know the steroids were done
partly because i couldn't afford it but
you immediately begin to learn about
what being fit means
i remember this moment i am i didn't i
didn't really have too much physical
training kit i just had the odd sort of
football shirt and
horrible jogging bottoms lying around
and it was uh
i don't know if you've seen it i think
it's sean penn run run fat boy run
at the moment when he he steps out the
doorway for his first training run
for his marathon and he's all overweight
and he's like stretching off in his
really crap yeah and i uh
i felt like that guy and i stood at the
doorway
of my house i was like i'm gonna go for
a run over the rest of your life
yeah but it was this it was like the
weather we have now it was just this
hit of fresh air and running and the
endorphins and the exercise
feeling like it was purifying me i
thought
this is what it feels like this is is
this what success feels like is this
what progression feels like is this what
it feels like
and that was that week alone of just
feeling myself getting slightly fitter
and healthier you know simple things
like tidying up my room
i was making myself homemade meals like
lasagnas and pastas because it was carby
and it felt like that was the right
thing to do
um and then i began to to start the
application process and
yeah it's about a year's process of
fitness tests
medicals well
psychometric tests and stuff like that
and then you go down and you do this
three-day course
before you start training you have to go
and do a potential royal marines course
which is
what i can only describe as a three-day
bee sting where they just
make you cry for three days and see who
survives it
and um i got food poisoning the night
before oh [ __ ]
yeah i literally threw the eye of a
needle and out the mouth and i was like
i'm in a [ __ ] state
a real [ __ ] state like a corpse in my
bedroom
and uh i remember my mum's saying again
she's like why don't you get and see if
they'll move it like in that mumsy way
yeah let's ask the marines if they'll
move it mum i just thought
i've just got to go and i went down and
i was last on every test
but i managed to scrape the times but i
couldn't put my hand up and be like
feel poorly like two three days into
becoming a royal marine it wouldn't have
gone down well
um but i passed and that for me was just
this incredible moment
of i've just managed to kick my
bad drug addict habits i
think i've overcome some sort of
suicidal tendencies here
to now be passing a course that's going
to give me the ticket
to begin training with one of the
world's most elite and respected
regiments
and that i didn't need anyone else
around me for that one to say well done
or that validation that was a look in
the mirror and go
nice one how did it feel when you got
that like was it a letter or an email or
it's uh it was literally there on the
spot you know you do the last day of the
three-day course and then they go
hey you passed or they go you [ __ ] you
failed off you go
and i had this letter which said uh
which said uh you passed you you'll hear
from your careers officers soon
you also get given this t-shirt i cringe
when i think about it now
but this t-shirt says potential royal
marines commander on the back
yeah and when i see people wearing them
now i'm like
and uh i put this t-shirt on and i was
on the train just like hold it and it
was freezing and i'm traveling through
i actually came back through london
because i was living in milton keynes at
the time
and so i was on the tube just like that
no coat on just a
t-shirt yeah but i was so proud of it
and i trained in that t-shirt every day
and uh
and then yeah i got my letter in the
post saying you'll be starting on
this date uh get yourself ready this is
your kit list this is what you're gonna
need
and that date came round but your mum
was proud right yeah
yeah she was really proud i think my
girlfriend was a bit
confused and a bit oh there he goes off
on a journey what happens to me
now um which is why i work so hard now
so which i'll come on to later but you
know
being stood i've been sat on that train
um for day one of training
and going from milton keynes and i went
up to birmingham and then i caught the
birmingham all the way down to exeter
i remember looking at people on the
train behind sort of newspapers and that
those glum sort of mp3 playing faces
with the
listening to their music looking out the
window and sort of cheap suits and
you know tapping away on laptops and i
thought i wonder if these people are
happy i wonder if these people are
on the journey i'm about to go on and
that
train ride in itself was extremely
fulfilling
and then the royal marines training
center's got its own
train line which is super scary to turn
up to
and then uh yeah i pulled up sort of
five hours later and
there's the first instructor awaiting
you and you you walk through the gates
you're carrying all your kit
quite bewildered but i remember thinking
i've arrived
it's crazy that you went from being i
almost have this vision in my head of
this young man who was
looking around for for something and
finding nothing
in terms of his purpose and then
obviously going within himself
and using you know cocaine and other
substances to try and
take to try and escape and then suddenly
it's like this
north star just becomes illuminated in
the distance and it's this sense of
orientation and direction and purpose
for your life
and um and that seems to be what you
know changed changed everything
obviously it takes a ton of resolve
because you know the way you've
described it
sounded i've got to be honest even
though you had these challenges along
the way
between like the moment when you decided
you saw that youtube video to when you
actually showed up at
the training camp but it's tough for a
lot of people to um
to even see the north star and then
pursue it
and especially when they're holding the
baggage of like addiction and i
find that pretty miraculous i'm like a
lot of people wouldn't be able to do
even that part going from
addiction and suicidal ideation to
putting on those shorts and going for
that run
i feel like that's that's the biggest
mountain to climb right like yeah
that was uh i think that was part of the
rush for me was actually just arriving
at the camp
and i'd watched a documentary by chris
terrell
um commando on the front line and it
followed a troop through commando
training which was quite
it wasn't an old grainy one it was you
know a year or so before i was going to
go there and i just
obsessively watched this
and at the time afghan had just kicked
off as well and
so they were getting combat footage of
what is happening out there right now
mix of this training and
and i remember watching this thinking
i'm going to be there soon i'm going to
be there i'm going to be there and it
took you know that's a year's worth of
sort of preparation and then i remember
standing in the foundation block which
is where you spend your first two weeks
with 60 guys i've never met before all
of us have shaved heads or
just look bewildered and a little bit
worried about what's next
and i remember looking around thinking
this is the room they filmed that first
episode in
i'm in it wow and you do think like what
legends have walked through here what
heroes have come through
everyone comes through that door over
there
and i think even that itself was a
real moment of pride like i really
enjoyed the first few weeks of training
and then it got quite hard to realize
that all right yeah it's quite a long
course and this is going to
take a lot of resolve as you say but um
you know those even those initial first
few days of just
excitement and looking around and just
being surrounded by excellence you know
the values have written on the wall your
corporals your troop sergeant your
captain they wear the green barrier of
pride and they're stood there
immaculately dressed
i'm gonna become you one day i'm
and we're having this conversation today
but something happened uh
in my life yesterday in fact so this is
i think why i'm really dwelling on this
point of like
how you go from the youtube video to
putting on that
pretty ugly gear that you found and then
going for the runners i've got a very
good friend of mine who
i know what miami saying this because we
talk about it openly
um who is going through tough times at
the moment he sounds very very similar
to the guy that you described who was
having those negative thoughts and was
looking for purpose in life and i'm
almost searching for the advice to give
him i think that's why i'm asking you
the question
because he is that guy that sat in his
car looking up at the sky wondering
what's the point in living
what is it that takes you from that
place to putting the shorts on and
saying do you know what
i'm going to do something for me for
once i'm going to help myself no one
else is going to get me out of this
situation but me
that bit there feels like the hardest
mountain to climb
i guess for you it was that sense of
purpose and prestige and that was
you know this had been your childhood
dream or like
there's also this quote i sometimes
ponder on which is change happens when
the pain of staying the same becomes
greater than the pain of making a change
like when life becomes sucks so much
that would ease it would be it would
suck less
to go and be beasted yeah yeah
you've got to want something that's what
i
looking back out having learned
everything along the way
it was the desire to want something
what is it i want um and it wasn't the
validation of being a tough guy at
all it was to be part of my dream
you know and you think back to that
nine-year-old he'd almost made his mind
up on the spot there that he's going to
join the marines and that kind of got
taken away and then i took it away from
myself anyway
and i think almost further away it gets
it becomes less tangible so when the
incident of the nightclub happens
and you find yourself becoming wrapped
around the wrong axle completely
you think it's getting further away i'm
losing control i haven't got it i'm
losing that thing i want
to that that finally that day of
something that reminds you to go
remember what you want to go
[ __ ] it i'm going to go and do it and
you know what i found i know a lot of
people like this
i still have a few of them my close
friendship group
um and i've worked with a lot of people
like this as well
where it's actually the courage to go
and do it
somewhere in your friend's head he'll be
thinking something that i wanna he may
look at you
yeah but you're successful it's easy for
you to say it
look how well you're living the dream
[ __ ] you you can't give me advice
and you're like oh dude come on switch
on
in there somewhere is something he wants
in there somewhere it's a desire
in there is a child who had an ambition
for doing something
and the older we get what i found with
my experience
it it feels like it gets slightly
further away and that gap gets bigger
and all of a sudden you've got to take a
bigger step or a bigger leap
but if you have that ability to go no i
do have the courage with it that that
gap closes
and it takes steps it takes baby steps
and people think it's overnight you know
you may have found this oh you're an
overnight success that's like 10 years
worth of hard work
you know messi says it took 15 years to
become an overnight success
that's because deep down in the shadows
those people which
are fighting every day the addiction the
difficulty the desire to go out in the
piss with our friends in the normal
world
to do the drugs to eat unhealthy food
whatever it is
is is that fight right there to go yes
or no
should i follow the easy option or
should i follow the hard option and
sometimes the hard option isn't the
challenge
sometimes the hard options the courage
you have to build within yourself to
take the steps you know that
um is there anything that i could have
said to you
when you were in that point in your life
when you were doing the drugs and having
suicidal ideation
if i was your friend is there anything
that i could have said to you that would
have helped you get out of it
because as friends and family members
we're always trying to change you know
help
right and i sometimes doubt the power of
a mate turn into you and being like pull
your [ __ ] together you know
it it strangely happened to me so
uh i won't mention his name because he's
doing sneaky beaky things these days
but there's a close friend of mine
what's sneaky beaky you know appearing
from curtains working for special forces
okay fine and things like that right not
perfect no no no no no no
yeah can't do that one again no he's not
perfect that's why i won't mention his
name
a friend of mine was within this
lifestyle i was with him
and um he decided to join the marines
and he got out of what we were embroiled
in
and i i remember ringing him like what's
it like what's like you know sort of
inquisitive about it and he just said
come and do it
and for me that was like this guiding
light it was
someone within my life who actually had
come away from what we'd all been doing
and plucked up the courage to go and do
it and it wasn't
some millionaire entrepreneur it wasn't
my mum it wasn't my dad
it wasn't a really senior marine it was
a friend
who was probably about 15 weeks ahead of
me on the process who's not even made it
himself
and is still going through the hardest
parts of training to say
come and do it come and give it a go
you've got this and that was
almost that not validation but that
boost to be like
yeah all right because that's a
relatable role model yeah he's just like
you
yeah it's someone i know it but it's so
real it's so
hang on he was with us 15 weeks ago i
know him i bring him and i'm like
wow okay i'm gonna i'm gonna follow in
your way
which in turn becomes quite uh
intimidating because you're sort of
social groups looking at it going well
the marines is really hard to get in
now two of them are there one of them's
guaranteed to fail aren't they shortly
and i'm looking at him going wow he's
stronger and tougher than i am is it me
and
that sort of creeps in every now and
then but it was that role model to have
seen i was as you were saying that i was
thinking that people will now look at
you
after being in the marines for you know
almost 10 years 10 years
10 years they'll see that that marine a
decade in they'll see ben
and they'll think oh god i can't i can't
do that he's you know like he's a big
strong man he's disciplined he's got
this mindset
like there'll be a kid sat in his
bedroom glancing at that youtube video
of the
you know the marines advert i think and
then looking over at ben and thinking oh
no i'm not i'm not ben he's all polished
and it's funny that it sometimes takes a
relatable role model to be the bridge
where you go do you know what there's a
guy that's halfway through the journey
who i know
and i'm like him and he's not special or
smart or whatever or rich
and that can that's the the bridge that
i'm gonna use to get in there myself
it's one of the things when i do the
podcast and when i talk about my story i
always want to
let people know that the guy you see now
that can talk and that can do this
business stuff and no social media
was like an idiot who like got kicked
out of school
can't spell still can't do maths well
it's just like you but as you say maybe
the
defining thing was courage and that
courage came from just
a delusional belief that i could this is
what i talk
this is why i wanted to write my book
commando mindset because
i wanted to um get people thinking
that a commando mindset is a particular
way of thinking within our world you
know to have a hundred percent of the
command of mind say you have to become a
commander you have to go through the
process and join up
um but everyone has to get themselves to
the gate
and i become quite interested in to get
into the gate part
to start and who doesn't get to the gate
you know the biggest critics never stand
on the start line with you
they're always the ones in the stand
given at the beginning aren't they it's
those on the start line who get to the
gate now i got to the gate
and i was really proud of getting to the
gate you know how cringe-worthy but
potential royal marines commando
yes at least i'm a potential royal
marines commander instead of a potential
civilian which i don't want to be for
now i want to go and live and
enjoy the world in different parts of it
um some
you wouldn't go to holiday on but um i
wanted to go and see it
and that that for me was a really
interesting point and you know
fast forward many years later i managed
to get the prestigious job of going back
to the commander training center as an
instructor
and get to see those people get to the
start line
and see them go on their journey and
listen to their stories you know you're
a bit of a tough guy over them at times
but listen to their stories
and hear them say that they had drug
problems
and this happened within their family
and or this person lived on the street
for this long
but now you're in my world and i'm going
to try and take you from
what you were and turn you into
something that
we need you to be but you have the
ability to be as well
and that process seeing them go from
civilian to commando
and that's really empowering
because i get to stand there on the last
day of training when
they finally do it and you can finally
call them mate
when uh you know it's a bit hard up to
that point it's like
good effort mate and you have a beer of
them and you tell them a little bit
about your story
they go whoa i thought you were like
this sort of
thing yeah untouchable [ __ ] just
yeah yeah
yeah that's it yeah yeah pretty much
but instead they realize you're a human
what is the commander mindset
are there principles to it what's the
philosophy you know you talk about it
being something that we can all
sort of reflect on in our own lives we
can all have that command in mindset i
guess in the home or in work
what other what is the commanding
mindset and
well we have an ethos that was the sort
of thing that
first jumped out at me when i got there
and we have values and the values is
pretty much what makes us courage
courage determination
excellence self-discipline integrity
cheerfulness
and humility and um
these words they're very human words
aren't they they're very you could put
that
in almost any walk of life and i think
people can acknowledge it and go
courage yeah excellence i have a bit of
that integrity is the biggest one we say
integrity in the marines is your
virginity you can only lose it once
and so when you have that way of
thinking and you have that ethos amongst
your peer group and your leadership
group um
you know most of the time what's coming
out of people's mouths is true
and that whether that's moral courage to
say we're the same rank
and you've got stop swearing nests and
you've got to take your hands out your
pocket
and you know let's set an example for
people who are below us
um to even you know being able to say
that to a senior commander
like oh should we have rounds in our
pockets right now sir but it's
this ethos within us that enables a
particular way of thinking
and it's when you're in the most extreme
circumstances when
bullets are coming at you i remember
my first ever combat engagement
i was we're in a quite a large patrol of
12
and we've been on the we'd flown into an
area in the green zone and told the
taliban are here you're just gonna have
to go and find them
which is like finding a needle in the
haystack sometimes and we were on the
ground for about four hours
and we always take an interpreter with
us and they have a radio that intercepts
taliban frequencies so they can actually
hear what the taliban are saying
and it was the first time i think i
heard the taliban as well you hear these
voices
and it's quite squiggly over the net you
can't really hear it properly but
you just think that's our foes that's
oh [ __ ] they can see us as well where
are they and they said
uh we can see and we can see them
they're heading towards the melon now
they're heading towards the melons was
their code word for
um ied improvised explosive device a
homemade bomb so the taliban is saying
across the radio that they can see you
they're talking to one another saying
they can see us and that we're heading
towards the bomb they've planted
and you start thinking well maybe
they're trying to egg us on maybe it's
not real we went into this farmer's
compound
and we stayed in there for about half an
hour to gain our breath and have some
water and
then they came back on so they've gone
in person they said his name as well
they've gone in his compound we'll pay
him a visit later
we'll get him on the way out so you're
looking at the poor farmer thinking
you're getting a knock on the door like
you don't need but also
we're in the safety of this small
compound that we're gonna step out back
into the open
soon and they're gonna they're gonna see
us and we stepped out the open
[Music]
and straight away we can see him again
we can see him again
and you again you kind of are they
trying to pull our bluff because they
know we can hear them they know
they know we listen to them um you kind
of take it sometimes with a pinch of
salt but you have to take it seriously
but then we had assets in the sky which
was a drone
saying that it can see fighting males
coming towards us all carrying weapons
and then moving down this street and
that was like
okay this is actually real and we hadn't
been hit by this point in the tour
and this was about to get very very real
and your whole
everything changes you know the
adrenaline's quite the adrenaline's high
but it's controlled
you've got control and you think i know
how to deal with this
stay focused and we came up to a ditch
which
there was it's almost like a t-junction
ditch where one met another
and then to cross it it was probably
about four foot deep and then you had to
pull one another out of it
and you get onto a track and then there
was a wall and the track sort of went
left and right from us and about three
of us got out the ditch
got onto the track and then just a hail
of bullets came flying down the track
and they all spat off the wall and off
the floor
and off the trees around us and what
you're taught to do when you're shot at
you're taught to do something called rtr
which is return fire whether that's from
the hip shoulder whatever just spray in
a direction
take cover return accurate fire rtr
i nose dived into the ditch
don't blame you yeah like quickly as
well and
just completely flopped into the water
my kit's probably wearing about 100
pounds so i've just gone straight to the
bottom of the ditch
and i'm beneath the surface and you can
hear the thumps overhead like
a split second you're underwater split
second
but it's long enough to go ah that
wasn't the right thing to do
that i've just done everything against
what i do in training and what i've been
taught to do you panicked right
yeah massively like oh [ __ ] someone's
shooting us what do we do jump in the
ditch that seems
like the cleverest thing to do and
jumped in ditch and i remember this
thought coming through my head
going oh you [ __ ] up big time there
get out the ditch
and i in that second came up out of the
water and noticed everyone had done the
same thing
so i was like right mark dodged that one
um and the way we were looking was down
the track so everyone sort of looking
across each other down
down the ditch and down the track and
there was one person still on
on the track returning fire on his own
stood up
literally you couldn't make it up it was
it looked like that sort of call of duty
image where he's just firing away on the
track
and it was our commander vicey um
and he just looked over all of us in the
ditch and went check your [ __ ]
flashes
and that is this internal system which
just
goes like that because your flashes are
what you wear on your shoulder
and it says the words raw marines
commando and everything those three
words mean
is related to the ethos related to our
values related to those 32 weeks
training related to every person that's
died for those flashes
and we're all hiding and he doesn't need
to say get out the ditch come on on the
track or anything like that
he just screams check your [ __ ]
flashes
and that's your reminder to go oh i need
to switch on and be a marine here
as opposed to hide cowardly in the ditch
and then we go out and you get into the
fight
and that's what the mindset the mindset
isn't necessarily just down to skill and
ability
it's that ability to tap into what
you're
programmed to do what your dna is what
your value system is have courage
have excellence have determination all
these things that
were just words up to that point have
true meaning for you to get into the
fight whether you lose your life
in the moment or not you're there to do
a job and that's what it looks like
and those values as you describe them go
back through that list again
courage one of them was joyful not just
cheerfulness in the face of adversity
why is that so important
that's the one that struck me the most i
was like that sounds like smiling
if you uh if you don't laugh at it or
laugh at you
and i i can't i've lost count the amount
of times where i've been soaked in mud
i'm absolutely hanging out and you know
a domino's pizza and being
at home and going miss and you look over
to the right and all you can see through
this
this muddy face is his teeth someone
else looking back at you and you just go
and you giggle and you know this is [ __ ]
isn't it yeah let's get on with it
because if you don't laugh at situations
that get tough
it is going to laugh at you and the
moment it starts to laugh at you
you're going to begin to suffer now it's
not
in the case of when people lose lives
you're stood over there going ah
having a giggle but it is those moments
of extreme warfare where rounds are
pinging off the wall in front of you and
you look at one another and go [ __ ] you
know that was close wasn't it
and you have the ability to laugh at
situations maybe other people wouldn't
laugh at
cheerfulness in the face of adversity is
is what we all need i've been saying it
to people
all last year and this year you know
this is [ __ ] what we're going through
but if you don't smile in some way or
another and find that
sort of courage to have a bit of morale
within yourself it's going to laugh at
you
that's where your mental health starts
to take a knock that's where you start
to have that
sort of negative downward spiral and
that was something i never had before
the marines the ability to laugh at
difficulty
and the marines encourages it out of you
what the other
words again so cheerfulness
courage determination determination
excellence
talk to me about excellence why that's
so important because i know from the
i've got to be honest i i feel like i've
watched every
documentary ever on like the sas and the
marines and
um the other special forces across
different countries i i got so obsessed
you know when i was younger
and one of the things that you see in
training is this obsession with
the the soup you know your uniform being
clean and your gun being clean and
things being in order and
it seems like from my outside
perspective they're like training
excellence and organization into you is
that
is that why they use the word excellence
in your flashes
um you can never achieve perfection
everyone looks at the military as in
they're perfect everything's shiny
everything's ironed everything's clean
but it's not perfect if you if you think
you've got perfection you've hit
arrogance or you've let your standards
down because
excellence is that ability to
continuously keep striving
towards something um my corporate
training said if you do not put
0.1 better every day at least you're
heading in the right direction
and his way of looking at that was you
could have the worst day ever you could
fail every test
but if you do something extra that day
that just boosts that 0.1
at least you're making a little bit of a
more positive impact on that day than
maybe yesterday you can
always strive and that word excellence
is
is embellished in that it's a it's the
ability to say
i can never achieve perfection
but as long as i strive to do my best
effort that's what excellence really
means that the
the ability to strive to put in your
maximum effort
on everything you do you could be the
slowest guy in the troop
and not be able to keep up with everyone
but if you are hanging out i always just
said to my recruits
i don't want to see you just giving me
the face for the sake of it i want to
see your face that you are fully
inserted in the locker
then i know you're giving me the best
effort because they're striving for
excellence
they're striving to just be the best
they can be
do we do enough of that we do in the
military
and that perfection doesn't exist you
can't aim for perfection
you have to aim for something a little
bit more tangible you have to aim for
something that
does exist and what does exist is the
ability to keep doing it at a high
standard how do you
in our culture at the moment there's a
narrative emerging which is like
at least you did your bet you know
there's a kind of a fluffy soft
so you hate it i can see it in your face
yes it's kind of like fluffy soft it's
okay that you're not that good
at least you know take rest well you
know good is a good
good is fine which is kind of
infiltrating our culture in a very pc
almost in my opinion toxic way if i post
this on instagram as i've said before
i'll get like cancelled because
people that sense of like doing less
than your best
and being negative seems to be
comforting
for people in a way that keeps their
self-esteem and ego
smothered with cotton wool so that they
don't have to take personal
responsibility
i can see you're very pissed off good go
ahead
yeah this podcast is over um
my lad took part in so i have a boy
zach he's seven and i have layla who's
three going on 18.
and uh he won a race
in sports day and i was like the marine
dad on the edge and they're like
godzilla you got this and he's flying
down and he's miles ahead of everyone
else it's like yes and he crosses the
line i'm like
yeah and he comes running over and he's
got this massive grin on his face and
he's got a big sticker
winner and there's another sticker next
to it
participator and uh i looked it and
instantly in my head i tweaked and i
thought
rip it off okay good are they handing
out them ones are they
and um he went i won hold on when he's
over over the moon
and my wife and i were like well mate
it's amazing
and uh he went why did everyone else get
sticker
and he was pissed off and i was like and
i could
i can almost hear the parents around me
i could hear their ears turn
towards me like oh how's this parent
gonna approach this one
and i did think in my head i was like
shall i go down there well it's good
that everyone had to go and everyone
took part
and then this kind of the stoic
commander went [ __ ] that
i went listen here no one else should
have got another badge right you're the
one who earned that
that's the reason you've got that
winner's badge don't worry about that
participation meter what i want you to
always strive just do your best every
time and you can win the race like you
did today
don't worry about everyone else and he
was like yeah but why do and it kind of
the conversation went off in child
language
sure um but why do they get a sticker
though dad and
like kind of looking around again at the
parents
i don't know i've not worked this one
out
yeah but i did i wanted to let him know
that that there was that parent in me
there's almost those two voices to go
go along with it because other people
are listening and this is now the new
cultural thing to do of just praise
effort
and sorry praise taking part over
anything else
or let my son you know one of the
marines values his integrity
i'll let him know what i truly think of
it i don't agree that they're handing
out those stickers mate
you won you won the race and you deserve
that one make sure you do that every
time
and he likes that people will listen to
that and they'll think some people might
think oh you're toxic
that's yeah those yeah pushy parents and
you're training your kid to you know
he'll end up like michael jackson
changing the color risk or whatever like
but if we look at the importance of
purpose and forward motion and
orientation
i think that removing accomplishment
removing north stars and just saying
nothing's an all-star and everything's a
north star
is actually really really dangerous
because
then if we don't have things to strive
for if there's no winner if there's no
accomplishment if there's no
mountaintops then again we lose our
orientation and that for me is where
people get depressed and have
opioid addictions and then they end up
killing themselves or you know whatever
else
it's also it's also maintaining a
standard
for not what i expect of my child
i want him to put the effort in if if he
doesn't want to put the effort in he
won't put the effort in
um and he will either go through a
process in life like i did or he won't
and he may look at my life lessons and
others around him and go we're not going
to do that i'm going to do this
i run a business you've run a business
if your staff
or employees sorry turned up i'm like
i'm just here
to you know get paid and nine to five
hit five and i'll go home you know that
turning up attitude what
what does that do for the culture of
that business you know you have too many
of those people
within your environment your business is
a car crash waiting to happen
you know it is the people within it or
your friendship group
your friendship group oh just you know
see what happened i'll just turn up
you know the just turning up attitude is
what we're encouraging when we say well
done everyone for taking part in this
race today
you know i i personally think you you
reward the top two
and and the one who's putting in maximum
effort who came in last
give him or her something as well you
know well done that's a good effort
we had um another cake yeah yeah
i didn't want to say you said it before
um i don't care about being canceled at
this point
yeah you're not cancelled my episode
but it's it is that it's if if we almost
reward this participation
now that's all you get rewarded as the
winner gets as much as the loser gets
and everyone in between gets rewarded
this
participation we are encouraging this
just turn up
just all you have to do is just turn up
and you get praise you win you know it's
what simon sinek talks about this kind
of entitlement where does it come from
well you just turn up you know
you get everything everyone else gets
anyway no like
you and i people who've had to work hard
fight hard the reason the green beret is
so well respected is
because it's so [ __ ] hard to achieve
the moment they drop the standard
you know it's not going to be the value
that it is at the moment
maybe that will happen maybe society
will push it through i know training was
very different to when i actually took
recruits through training you know i
have seen that difference in culture
society is having an impact on that we
are rewarding people for just turning up
simply just turning up and that to me is
it's not we're not breeding this
michael jordan attitude we just want you
to come and give your best effort the
excellence turn up and strive
don't just turn up and tick boxes that's
a big
thing that i took away from the military
is do not tick boxes you know
you can get your report we were always
encouraged with our reports to be
way better on it you know don't just you
know well done you've done everything
you need to do in these couple of months
it's good after you've done all this and
this
that's what we look for it's funny
because people just her
state of mind and the kind of soft
fluffy cultural
narrative that's kind of breaking
through especially on like social media
i think is designed to try and protect
your mental health but i think that the
argument we're saying is it
it actually has the adverse effect
because it takes away that sense of like
striving and accomplishment
which is so clearly important for people
to live
fulfilled lives and uh it goes back to
the point i made about
you know chaos being stability and
stability being chaos if
if even in my industry there was no
competition there was no podium there
was no
nothing to aim for my life would descend
into some form of like probably
some form of depression because i would
have no there would be a purpose
and although you know the mountaintop or
the podium actually isn't the moment
of purpose the journey is like the
striving the training the
whatever it's important to have it there
um
and i i'm glad we had that conversation
because i think a lot of people don't
melons you mentioned the word melons
earlier on
the taliban talking about they planted
their melons so i heard that it was in
fact
one of those melons one of those ieds
that took you out of the military
yeah it was the catalyst for sort of end
of my career
um i've got something really exciting to
share with you
last week as many of you might have seen
in the press it was announced that i
would be joining
the board of huel and for you guys that
know me well and know how much
i drink you all and how much it's been a
key part of my life and running my
business and staying healthy
will know why this is exciting to me
because it's a product that i absolutely
love
and the reason why they sponsored the
podcast in the first place was because
when i knew that i was going to be
bringing it back and investing in the
you know the the production of the
podcast and the team i wanted a partner
who i could talk about authentically
without having to [ __ ] you
and heal is that partner so i reached
out to huell and said listen i'm
starting my podcast
um up again and i'd love you to be the
sponsor of it and so as i've got closer
and closer to julian some of you all
know he actually came onto this podcast
and he will be coming back on in the
future
um we realized that there was a lot
professionally we could do together and
upon leaving social chain
i got a ton of offers to join boards to
join companies to be an advisor a
consultant you can imagine
what my inbox looked like immediately
after the announcement and i said no to
everything i'm a firm believer
in rejecting good and the whole doubt
for grey and when julian had the
conversation with me
i said yes to joining hughes board in
less than a
second i knew what he was gonna end the
sentence with so i said yes before he
ended it
and um i've started working with the
team now on products on their comms on
the
wider business on the brand everything
and it's amazing i absolutely love it so
what started as a little podcast
sponsorship what started as a
conversation with a remarkable
entrepreneur and julian has now become a
more formalized relationship
and i'm a board member of huel and i
think it's important to be honest with
you about that because
when you hear me talking about it now
you know that i'm actually in the
building so
yeah just wanted to share that with all
of you back to the podcast
you mentioned the word melons earlier on
the taliban talking about they planted
their melons i heard that it was in fact
one of those
melons one of those ieds that took you
out of the military
yeah i was the catalyst for sort of end
of my career
um yeah we
we were deployed on an operation around
three or four weeks before the end of
this particular tour in 2011 um
and yeah it was called the hornets nest
it was just an area
i've heard that before yeah it's not
it's not nice when your commanders say
you're heading into the hornet's nest
and when they follow that up with we're
going to go and hit the nest
okay all right good luck i'll see you
okay postcards
now um but it it the idea was to go in
and disrupt the taliban an area they
thought they were untouchable within
and we knew it was going to be heavily
contested and they had the civilians
on hand there they they had it all and
it was
really deep in the green zone as well
which i think this is sort of
end of august beginning of september so
the crops are at seven eight foot
um the tree lines are sort of every
hundred meters and the trees are very
high it's just a really difficult place
to operate in
it's like a jungle in the desert and
then
we landed on the americans gave us a
lift in the morning dropped onto target
and within about four or five hours we'd
had
um five guys taken out the game already
by a grenade which came into the
compound and just detonated at their
feet
taken out of the game yeah so injured
and put back on stretchers and put
straight back on the helicopters
um we then took
attack well we started to receive an
attack from three different angles
um so they were firing us from the
bearings right north west and south um
and there were firings from two
different angles from a distance to
distract us from
an attack which was coming in from this
third angle which was to sneak up to the
gate
and try and get into the compound so we
were sort of really trying to fend off
and and this
came sort of every half an hour it would
just pick up and then it'd drop off and
move
scrapping all day it got to the point
that if you weren't on the roof fighting
you were trying to get your head down to
get some sleep and then ready yourself
to go up and things would
explode and you'd wait wait for a scream
or wait for something
and then the firearm has started going
oh everyone's alright just carry on it
was just the most surreal situation
um and we ended up fighting with the
enemy pretty much all day that day
and then we needed to push patrol out in
the morning and that morning
that morning just had this weird feeling
about it you know the day before
five guys had been blown up by a grenade
you know covered in frag
um we'd had some injured civilians come
in
it was just just quite a chaotic day the
taliban had got right up close to the
gates and we've managed to push them
back and kill a few
and it just kind of leaves you the
feeling the next day thinking oh we've
got another six days of this seven day
operation
another six days of this um you know
that first day we were there it got that
bad that mortifier was getting called in
over us
landing literally 50 meters in front of
the compound to stop them advancing on
our position
and that's frightening that's you know
you're close to that sort of hand-hand
combat
and um the next day i remember waking up
thinking i didn't have a great night's
sleep
you don't really get good night's sleep
out there and this
really weird thing happened i i was sort
of messing around with
the some ornaments which were on a shelf
you know just like being a nosy sort of
brit having a look around this compound
and i ended up flicking this
sort of like weird dish thing it had a
car battery
like just a half a car battery in it and
i poured it
and it had all the acid in it and it
leaked onto my head and then onto my
face and then onto my body
i was like oh my god i've got battery
acid on me and i even
said to myself i was a bad omen for the
day isn't it
um and there was just these like weird
tiny little events that happened and i
think they only seem weird now because i
look back and like because there was
an incident and um one of uh
one of the marines uh darlow luke
he um we usually rotate on patrol
so on one patrol he would go at the
front or second from the front because
of the weapons we carried
um i carried a light machine gun which
is um
you know it's between the we have two
machine guns we have the gpmg and then
we have the lmg and the lmg's slightly
smaller and i had the lmg
and so you go that second person to
cover the first person
who's a rifleman who is literally with a
metal detector looking for the bombs so
you're there on their shoulder and you
work as a pair
and it was actually my turn to go in the
middle of the patrol
and it was luke's turn to go up to the
front and
neither position really is any skin off
your nose i was like doing a swap today
and he's like now stay where i am i'll
go jordan up the front
and we came out the compound and
literally straight away
into a ditch and then into a cornfield
and we kind of navigated our way through
the cornfield and the idea was to get up
to this village was which is probably
about 200 meters from our
sort of um base i suppose you could call
it an occupied compound
um and we just wanted to get in there
and talk to some of the locals and
see what the problem is with the taliban
and where they are and see what
intelligence we can get out of them and
i i was a jordan at the front and with
us was a dog handler and we had the dog
handler because they sniffed the bombs
and we came to the edge of the cornfield
and there was just no one around
call it atmospherics so positive
atmospheric
women and children out in the streets
farmers in the fields you know
normal life pattern of life happening
there was
no one nothing like literally you had
the tumbleweed going down the street
um and i looked over my shoulder and you
could feel it we call it spidey senses
it's when you know
your skin and your hair so it starts to
stand up on your neck
and you could just sense it after
yesterday's fighting
no villagers around they're here the
taliban are here it's just where are
they
um i looked over my shoulder and vicey
was behind me my commander it was just
like yeah push up the track let's go
and we came out onto the track and began
walking up towards where we needed to be
very slow pace you know you're checking
for these bombs in the ground
and a tractor appeared in front of us
probably about 20 minutes 20 meters to
our front
and this this farmer just looked at us
and he must have just seen
load of marines suddenly stood there in
the street and just we were like
thresh you know stop and he just like
floored the tractor as much as he could
it kind of just chugged off and he
disappeared
and it just it just all felt a bit weird
and
we got nearer to this um we literally
come up to this crossroads
and myself jordan the dog handle were on
top of the crossroads now
or just just slightly just before jordan
was on it and i was just slightly back
from it
and these two guys walked around the
corner dressed in full black
trainers on which is a massive indicator
for taliban they used to wear trainers
where most of the people just wore
flip-flops and these trainers for
obvious reasons getting around quicker
and they would just stood there as you
are to me in front of us
and it was like [ __ ] out and
you couldn't do anything like they're
not armed they just stood there looking
at you
and they're as wide-eyed as you are and
you think this is taliban
and then they just bolted literally just
ran straight from us as we're like stop
stop and they ran to our right
behind us a short wall but into the
field and you could hear him like
traveling through the field like the
snapping of the
corn and everything and why the [ __ ] are
they just running to the field why
didn't they run down the track or just
stop
and all this is starting to go in your
head and i turned around and looked at
vice and he went
[ __ ] run now and we'd start to run
and we'd
we must have taken two three steps and
the wall next to us just
obliterated and this this plume just
covered us all
like i've never heard anything that loud
i've been around a few loud things
but it was so close and i remember this
something hit me in the back of the head
um which my helmet must have deflected
and then something went through my leg
and i just felt like this almighty pain
in my leg and
but i was still stood there and i don't
mean that heroically like
shrugged off a bomb it was just a shock
of it everything just went through you
all the rubble
um all the um frag
fragmentations to the shards of metal
just just went through your bags helmet
everything
and the pain in my leg was enough for me
to like
scream out in agony and then drop to the
floor and the way i dropped
i actually ended up sitting on my foot
so my injured leg had come
back under me and i had this right leg
out
to the front i smile because it was
mildly amusing when i look back on it
but all this you know your ears are
ringing you can't hear it you just hear
that sort of
muffled sudden sound um
you can smell the core diet you can
smell
horrible things you know when you come
to terms with what happens next
i remember looking down thinking oh it's
[ __ ] me and i was screaming i've lost
my leg i've lost my leg because i just
i was concussed i had the pain here i
couldn't see it there's lots of smoke
and dust everywhere and
[ __ ] i've lost my leg i had this
moment sat literally must be 30 seconds
long sat there on the floor thinking
[ __ ] i've lost my [ __ ] leg where is
it for a start
um and then it was like this weird
sensation of like my
foot trying to come back round
underneath me and it and then i was like
oh [ __ ] sat on it i'm sat on my foot
i sat on my foot and i did look down and
there was blood all down my legs but
my foot was there my leg was there it
was all intact and you check other bits
which are quite
required for a man and i was like all
right it's all there
and you do have those really surreal
moments it's a real thing where people
check themselves
and i was like [ __ ] but then it real
then you realize you're on patrol
and there's other people on that patrol
and there's 12 of us out on the ground
right now
and that thing which just happened was
very very close
and it was almost at the moment i turned
around that the the
orange dusty smoke was clear in that
everyone was lying on the floor
uh three of which were just out cold
completely
and it was just this stark realization
like
[ __ ] we've been hit hard there and the
wall had
this little small wall which obviously
the device was hid behind
you know you quite quick quickly know
what's happened
as they've planted a device behind the
wall which is facing the path
and they've run into the field at the
end of a wire and just connected the
battery
and it's detonated on our patrol and
what it is is called directional
fragmentation so it sprays across the
patrol instead of coming up from under
the ground
and everyone had been hit everyone and
behind me was my
corporal vicey out
blood coming from his neck blood
everywhere kit
weapons clothes just ripped to pieces
and you just think
[ __ ] and there's no one else around like
it's just you guys
on the track and most of them are lying
unconscious on the floor
and i started thinking i thought to
myself i've got to get to vicey
so i started crawling i was in utter
agony as well
i just knew i had to get to him and as i
was getting nearer i could see that
he'd been struck in the neck and it was
doing as you would see on casualty
coming out
at an angle and you'd i've been in these
moments before i've been around people
which lost legs have been
there for people which have been injured
but there was people left and right
you know there was your team were there
on this occasion everyone's just [ __ ]
out cold
and as i was just getting to visey a
marine came sprinting up the track from
right at the bottom
and just jumped onto his neck like with
his knee literally jumped onto his neck
and just lent into him and he started
shouting at me going get your [ __ ]
kit out now get your kit out
and so i started fiddling around for my
medical care and what we were trying to
get out was this thing called
hemclot which is like um it's like a
bandage
but it's uh it basically you stuff it
into a wound and it expands
um and i needed to get my henclot out
but you have to throw it's like this
technique that you take out throw it
over your shoulder so it doesn't get
caught in the dust
and you have to keep it over your back
so you can then put it in but you're not
packing all the [ __ ] in around them
and uh he's like get your [ __ ] head
glow out now and he's
now obviously removed his knee from his
neck and he's got his fingers in the
wound
and he's trying to hold on and so i
remember looking at her thinking he's
trying to hold on to his artery there
and he's trying to pinch his artery
going stop [ __ ] looking start putting
it in there
i was trying to do it and he grabbed it
off me went i'll do it hold that and
then you're there like
[ __ ] now i'm holding it literally
pinching it together going don't go
don't go don't go
and then the medic came up from the back
and barged me out of the way and
start started treating him on the spot
um
and all i could do was just hold his
hand and was just like pray for your
kids stay few kids stay with us stay
with us
and i just sort of 45 minutes flashed by
and we were on the helicopters and we're
back at kambastian and they were going
through triage and
i don't know miraculously they're still
with us today
um vice lost his leg in that moment as
well which is unfortunate
darlow who i was meant to swap with took
fragmentation through the temple
and is now disabled because of it but
he's still with us and
uh it's still great fun to be around
still
marine at heart definitely and a few
other lads taking it in the throat
all over their bodies and you kind of we
meet up every now and then you know not
so much now but we meet up we call it
the bangiversary
and you look at these kind of reprobates
which are still just got scars all over
them and you share the stories and you
take the piss out of one another
and vice always says to me he's like you
were crying when i was dying when you
know i was like
yeah [ __ ] was but it's
it's a part of that journey you know and
it was a real intense moment but um
we signed the dotted lines we put
ourselves in that position and
um that's what happens in war at some
point you decide
that you can leave or you would
discharge medically or yeah it was um
i was discharged because of my hearing
and it was something i'd hid from that
day
i knew my hearing had been affected but
the way the sort of
hearing tests work in the military you
can kind of blag it you press it every
three seconds and it'll
it'll look roughly like you can hear it
and i could never hear properly in my
left ear
and they changed the test uh several
years later and i got caught out
trying to blag it and the doctor was
like what are you doing
hearing test yeah stop doing the three
second rule
all right do it properly and did it
properly
and then it was like you can't hear any
left ear can you i was like i can hear
something
then let's have a chat and yeah we
sort of that was the ball rolling
between being elite military to leaving
the forces
not easy to leave as they say life
change is very different
yeah have something to aim for that's
what i decided this
moment they told me i think i'd been up
threw enough stuff up to that point to
go okay this is what happens now
adversity strikes you've got to work out
how to get through it
um i i had a
i had this ability to coach people
like that's what i did with my young
marines and then when i worked with the
rehabilitation troops as well
i thought i could do something outside
here and
fortunately as i was sort of in my year
of discharged
gareth southgate brought his motley crew
down to meet us at the commando training
center and i got to meet some pretty
cool characters within the england
football team before they went to the
world cup and
that's where i realized that no this
commander mindset thing can actually be
transitioned and help people way away
from the military
how do i do this but between that gap of
leaving and
you know starting your next sort of
chapter
i was reading that you had you suffered
with ptsd and you were
you know because it would be
conceivable that someone would then fall
back into the old patterns
right like losing your purpose again and
then like losing your sense of
orientation and
was that a i think i had that
relapse or i know i had that relapse
actually
not long after afghanistan and i think
this sort of trauma you go through
the way you may handle it
and what you've seen and all these
things it's
it's hard to get your head around is
really hard especially when you come
home so quickly it's like
bang explosion you're back in the uk i
remember being at um
the queen elizabeth hospital up in
birmingham
and it had been 36 hours since we
triggered well since the taliban
triggered the
device on us you know literally two days
ago we're fighting them
coming up to our doorway and then i was
sending this sort of crisp
white sheet bed white sheet bed looking
out over birmingham
and my mum came in you know this woman
who
i admire so much and i didn't want to
speak to her i was like i don't want to
speak to you i want to speak to you
i want to speak to you i don't speak to
anyone leave me alone because
i was still an afghan and i genuinely
think even to this day
a part of me still stayed there and i
could never get my head around it so
when i when i
you know rehabbed and i was fit and i
could go back to the unit
i would drink a fight
i ended up getting court-martialed and i
was suddenly spiraling back towards
that bend before the royal marines you
know using that
violent way of being and taking a
substance to sort of numb the pain which
in this case was drink
and again it was this ah back at square
one
done this career all right just i've
just fought for my country
and now i've got to go and stand in
front of the judge which ironically was
over an incident now i was defending
someone else for when someone pulled a
knife out you know it was just
it kind of felt like really i'm actually
trying to do something good here and i'm
getting punished for it
but that's uh maybe the naive way of
looking at it but it it was
a difficult moment i had to begin to
process what happened in afghan and it's
it was just another moment of processing
as we keep almost coming back to is how
we process stuff and
afghan was tough you know we lost people
we we lost lives we lost
people lost limbs a lot of people lost
limbs there was this constant
battle in your head because of the ied
threat
you can never see him so you would walk
out on the ground and think i wonder
where i'm gonna put my foot today and
that
that's like seven hours long every day
that that has its toll on you like
constantly looking like that everywhere
you go
i remember when my then fiance we moved
into the flat together i was
really mad at her for the way she
stacked the bean cupboards i was like
what the [ __ ] aren't they facing the
same way for and she was like why are
you being like this
they need to because then when you go to
say because you've got nothing for that
because they
just [ __ ] do it and now that's me
still like packing my kit regimently at
the end of my bed what if we get
attacked we need to be good to go
um and it's it's so hard to
they call it decompression it's so hard
to decompress from that
and you feel so pent and i remember
coming back thinking
no one respects us like it seemed like
the civilian world didn't care the
london riots were happening
you know i can't even get it right on
our own shores let alone trying to help
other people out and you just felt
forgotten
and it wasn't you who felt forgotten you
felt the lives had been forgotten and
everything
which isn't the case you you know i meet
so many people now it's like
wow that's amazing to me thank you so
much for what you've done for the
country
and you get to this humble point now
we're like yeah
thanks i signed the dotted line i'm so
pleased you appreciate it
um but back then it was this kind of
bitterness of why don't you care
i've just done this why don't you care
and it took me about a year to get
through that
and i i look back now and think i think
that's actually quite natural
for a lot of the marines that they went
through and soldiers
and then i got that turning point of
picking up my leadership courses to then
go and work with recruits and that was
it for me
i was like even though i was dodging and
weaving the hearing tests
i get to invest something back now and i
get to
make the next breed of marines come
through and that became your new sense
of purpose
right that was yeah and it's such a
valuable thing for me to do
um we ended up moving the fam well my
wife moved down pregnant we had zach
down there we made a life and
i really felt like it was just it was
just brilliant to be part
of their journey and see them progress
and that's what the purpose became it
was seeing people go from a to b
and being part of their journey to say i
believe in you
you need to believe in yourself and you
see them progress and even that comes to
the england football teams like
you can do this if you put your mind to
it and they got that close
very close let's talk about that then so
where is gareth southgate and you ending
up sort of working with the england
football team just before they went off
to uh russia
yeah russia yeah yeah um
[Music]
they came they came down to get a taste
of our world that's how i was literally
put
and the idea that they would come down
and be immersed in
some activities that we do they do some
of our assault courses
but they'd also be introduced to the
mindset that's what gareth wanted to do
most and he wanted to introduce them to
our values again that was a really
important part of their whole trip was
to know what courage looks like what
does excellence looks like
self-discipline humility integrity all
those words
and um it was it was very surreal
you know i felt like a giddy kid most
the time you know knowing that they're
in the buses they're almost at the
training era we were
we were up in one of the woods that we
trained in and there was
me and four other corporals five other
corporals and our sergeant
and you could see the bus turning up and
we were like oh they're coming
literally like we were like that like
then you had a tough guy yeah that was
it yeah troop sergeant was like when
they come over that wall don't forget
like you gotta put it all on though boys
all right
yeah roger no worries taff laughing and
then harry kane appeared first and we
were like
like staring him down and then i just
remember
tafar sergeant just went why are you
staring
at kane and just started bellowing at
him and
get on your kit then and then we all
jumped in oh god then south gate start
moving
and um it was brilliant you've thrown
that for a little while
but actually they're there to understand
you and that's not actually who we are
um i was you know surreal moment one
o'clock in the morning drinking
or sharing a cup of tea with harry over
a little fire
talking about uh what it's like to score
in front of 80 000 people what's it like
to
wheel away and you turned into a fanboy
yeah
massively and even when i was asking i
was like ah don't ask the question but
you know what he answered it in a way
that
it wasn't to the fans it wasn't to the
press
he genuinely answered it which i've you
could hear it was like
there's nothing like it you know the way
you just the way you just expressed it
and so you can see him staring at the
floor a bit as he's saying it as he's
thinking about those moments
yeah he's visualizing and so yeah that
was amazing and but then he asks you is
like
you know what's warfare like um
and again that sort of stumps you a
little bit like wow the england
captain's just asked me what it's like
in afghan
you have this conversation it was just
so normal it got that normal
that i started moaning to him about
holiday prices
because i just paid for the family to go
to lanzarote
on an all-inclusive and i was like and
then and
in holiday prices through the roof at
the moment i just paid three grand today
and then i'm thinking he's just got that
from dubai he's probably just done all
these things
but he was so humble with it and it was
a really genuine
organic conversation and we found that
with a lot of the guys
and girls which came you know they
bought the whole set up with them
kit man to gary southgate and everyone
in between
and they just wanted to see our world
and see what
values mean when you're going through
different things you know when you're in
the mud and water it's very easy to be
in that position
and feel like oh this is [ __ ] but when
someone's going
this is what courage looks like this is
what this looks like this was what this
looks like you know
it helps frame it in a different way and
it helps show you what your ability is
what you can do what what that meaning
of that word is
and that was something that we kind of
encouraged them to take to the world cup
and
i think they did i think they did and
there's been a lot of press around it as
well so
yeah they did well would have been
awesome i i've read one of your uh
your podcast all your interviews
whatever where you said um
had they beaten i think it was croatia
wasn't it you were set to go on pierce
morgan's show the next day and explain
yeah
exactly how you how you helped them get
there but then they lost
we had a focus literally yeah so i'm
cheering going come on england
we're made after this come on yeah yeah
yeah
it's a hard time um but it didn't happen
but hey
you know later i think it was january 19
i went and did the keynote for gareth at
the football writers awards at the savoy
and i did mention and and i know a lot
of people phrased it
but there was an element of pride to be
part of that journey
and say you know they didn't bring the
trophy home but they definitely bought
football home
and i think it's really unfortunate that
we didn't have it this year you know
that
oh gosh they were last year so much
whatever it's meant to be last year
wasn't it
2020 it was yeah some wasn't yeah yeah
it's almost 20 20 euros yeah
so but it i thought i thought it brought
the nation a little bit closer
personally
you the other thing i was intrigued by
was i read this i think it's a
r a um sort of strategy per se which
um you've adopted to help you deal with
difficult situations
could you could you explain that a
little bit yeah so
ara was almost kind of made up on the
spot when i was trying to think of some
things to deliver to people
and and i've written ara's quite a focus
within my book because we all encounter
adversity we all
encounter challenge and one of the
biggest things i've noticed with myself
and then when you look at it objectively
with other people
when people encounter adversity there's
almost that
fight flight or freeze mode people go
into there's oh i'm going to take this
on
or i'm going to bail out and hide in the
ditch or i'm just going to stand there
and
there's a lot of research around most of
us actually freeze
we just don't know what to do um
and for me going through a lot of
experiences
you know where i really go back to is
when we lost our first person in battle
d we lost eno and we lost dina within
five minutes of the 24 hour operation we
literally ran off the back of the
helicopters
at sort of 4 30 in the morning we were
going to take a village
and helicopters went trooper crossing
the ditch to get into the village
stepped on an ied
blew him up and he was gone um
and he died there and then on the spot
and two of the other guys were injured
severely with him as well and you just
i've used it a lot within football i
call it three nil down within one minute
and it's that moment of
wow we're on the ropes already we've
only just started this thing we're on
the ropes
how do we deal with it what do we do and
i remember you know these
incredible emotions go through you when
someone gets killed you know you feel
anger
you feel rage you feel you want to cry
you do you want to just take a knee and
look at the floor and go i can't believe
he's dead let's mourn it right now
but you've got 16 17 quite hungry
taliban on the other side of the wall
who want to kill you as well
and the worst thing you can ever do is
is go into
a village or an area such as that
emotionally charged if you go in
emotionally charged
you're going to make cataclysmic errors
that could be that you're so
sad or overwhelmed that you're not
concentrating you miss that person in
the corner they then take you or someone
else out
or you go in there angry and when you go
and they're angry
you make serious mistakes and you don't
have to look far and oppressed to see
that happened and that happened on our
tour
um and that emotion gets in the way of
dealing with the situation and what i
like to more frame as
thinking with clarity it's so hard to
think
with clarity during adversity and that's
why i spent quite a bit of time thinking
well
what is a quick framework we can just
jump to what have i used
an ara simply stands for accept remove
adapt the moment something happens then
on the spot it's happened and then it's
instantly gone so someone dying on the
spot
in combat is there's nothing you can do
about it there's
nothing you can do about it the most
effective thing you can do
is be it your highest standard strive
for excellence
get up on that roof and do what you need
to do to the people which have hurt
your comrade that's that's that's how
you should be posting it what is still
the strategic
operational part of what we're doing
here and
the the accept part is very difficult
for a lot of people to do
it's very and i still struggle with it
now myself but actually having that
little framework to go
alright okay this isn't good how do i
accept the situation has
happened or happening how can i process
it
and without dwelling on blame or exactly
or you know
or bitterness is there another one like
say
your business is shut down because of
kovid you're angry at boris johnson
you're angry at
everybody and you dwell on that so
that's the first hurdle is as you say
accepting which is
tough tough but it's a mindset you know
this isn't for me this is not something
we should shy away from you know the
moment say
it's tough does that then allow people
to go
well i'm not doing it then just i'll
just turn up sympathy can sometimes show
up as well too much sympathy maybe
a victimhood the except is it's happened
what is the next move what is the next
thing i need to do
um we lost almost all of our work with
our business last year we
we were working in talks and coaching
and doing workshops
overnight gone like i could have sat
there which i did for about half a day
going
oh what the [ __ ] where's that all gone
but you can't how long do you sit there
doing that for before
you just start to take a spiral down or
where do you actually go right
what can i actually do with this where
can i make a decision
we could become so emotionally wrapped
up in covert as well the pandemic alone
like i've i've
expressed a hell of a lot of empathy and
sympathy to everyone i work with saying
this is probably one of the toughest
things we've all been through
collectively in a long time we're
literally playing stuck in the mud for
real
you know we're grounded and it
does become quite an emotional place
doesn't it people losing jobs things
going wrong
but part of ara is this remove emotion
is not becoming emotionless like not
asking you to be motionless it's
for me in combat it happens you've got
to deal with it then and then remove the
emotion get the anger and the sadness
out the way
do you know what we'll do we'll deal
with that later no we've got to deal
with that correctly as well this is
where some people make the mistake of
bottling up
i'm going to come back to that later but
i need to get on with my job
and that part is that adapt part okay
how do we adapt to this situation how do
we adapt to
loss of life there what was his role not
who is he as a human what was his role
what do we need to do to fill that role
for now while we're here
um i was telling you about that time
when we were having to use mortar fire
as almost a curtain
as the taliban metroid commerce on that
final operation
the person calling in that mortifier was
vice my commander
and he's not a mortiman he is not
trained on the radio to do that
the day before when we lost those five
guys who were by a grenade one of them
was the mortiment
and he was the one who needs to call
that stuff in we didn't have him
you have to learn to adapt and we could
sit around and say oh we've lost our
morton and we're [ __ ] now
or we can go right he's gone let's not
cloud our judgment
let's think with some clarity and get
the emotion out the way okay
how do we adapt to this situation and
i've had so many people which is really
genuinely humbling because i kind of
didn't make it up i just wanted to
put a little bit of an acronym on what i
use and give it to other people
and i have so many people get in touch
saying ara because it's a simple process
maybe in the morning you know when you
stub your toe stub your toes like the
quickest like ah
you just want to go band's eye on the
table don't you but you just go stop
i've stubbed my toe yeah yeah it does
hurt yeah i need to be a little bit
less emotional with this table and now i
need to adapt to the fact that my toes
facing in different directions
so we all look at the table now but it
is it is something
you know something just happens and you
have to be able to go
all right that's happened how do i
remove the unwanted emotion i call it
unwanted emotion what's the bit that's
going to get in your way
if you're making the right decision the
anger the um
the sadness whatever's there and then
you have to adapt i always think that
the first l you take and when i say l i
mean loss the first l
you take is often involuntary
nothing you could do whatever the second
l you take is often voluntary
so like the pandemic happens wasn't your
fault we get that
but then you dwell on it so much and you
refuse to adapt and you
you become a victim of circumstance you
become bitter and blaming
and you don't adapt as you say which was
your choice
and that leads to another l which is
your business goes bankrupt
and so i always think like the first i
always say that's like you don't have to
take the l twice
the first l is you know involuntary the
second one is your choice and that's
i think the similar sentiment to the
importance of
like getting rid of that unwanted
emotion focusing on
the task at hand finding that calm
within your within the chaos
and being proactive and as you said as
the sort of military values
being cheerful because that is uh
optimism is a very important
uh emotion to experience in times of
real chaos you have to believe that
there is a way out
um and that's super interesting i i i
was reading through your story as well
more recently i read about i think you
touched on this earlier
this joy that you've now found in
running during the pandemic yeah
yeah tell me about that i don't like it
as well do i just say well
i started training in march as well and
i've been training all year
so i thought that was really interesting
you mentioned earlier that getting out
and feeling the air and the endorphins
and
yeah i um i was never a great runner in
the marines
not really no i was more the one who'd
put the big backpack on and just be able
to plod on um
your son could give you some tips yeah
that's who i train with now
um i just i i really
i like the idea of just it sounds so
forrest gump
but just running there's i have no
reason to run
i i think during the pandemic i found it
a nice bit of an escape
you know we're locked inside all the
time uh you're on zoom call
after zoom called the kids are
downstairs and
um you just need that moment to yourself
and
and i just love being out there running
i just it's interesting my business
partner and
um his wife asked me the other week
she's like why why do you run
i don't know you know it got me
pondering so i think maybe i'm a little
bit better prepped to answer your
question
um but it was
i use this word escape loosely because i
think i've used
the word i i've escaped before in the
past through
drink and drugs and the more sinister
things
escape now is actually just to be of
myself for a while
and i find that and and you would have
found this on your own business journey
is
it's so full on all the time it's just
someone wants you for something your
phone pings or
you know i'm i use social media i don't
have the biggest following but
i use social media because it's part of
what i have to do you know promoting a
book and things like that
i don't really want to be on it i
actually kind of like my reserve
lifestyle but i have to give you
something to show you what i do
um which i was listening to i think as
jake talked about on your podcast
this morning it was really interesting
it put my ears about thinking about it
but running is i don't have my social
media on when i run
i'll if i need to i'll record a video to
be like oh i'm not running
um and post maybe sometimes but i just
like being out i like feeling a bit of
the pain in the shins and in the feet
and i like running further than other
people do not for time
but that idea of what my corporal said
to me in training 0.1
better every day i i really enjoy
just striving for that excellence and i
have found since leaving the military
it's really difficult to feel like
you're constantly striving for
excellence it seems like there's more
challenges there than there is
success to be honest it's like one thing
after the other i've done this within
the business are we oh that's good oh
something else come along which is
difficult to deal with now isn't it
brilliant
um but for me being out running is that
ability to escape i live in a wonderful
part in the southwest you
you know that area very well up onto
dartmoor up onto the southwest coast
um you just just incredible places to be
and take the dog out running
and i actually found in probably the
last year or so
it's an incredible space to think and i
run back and
i actually pick my post pace up at the
end because i cannot forget that
yeah you're not running back home
through the door and you're like what
about this with this yeah that might
work
but it's um it's just a place to be free
you know and i'm not real
a gym bunny i don't really i go to the
gym i kind of walk around it look at a
few things do the odd pull up and then
go home
i love being out on the road and i love
being out on the muddy trails as well
slipping around getting wet getting
muddy
it's just fulfilling isn't it i think
when i was in the military that was all
the time and now it's not when i left
when i
when i got binned from the military
my last final day i came home i laid on
the floor
and it sounds i say that about social
media i don't really like using it but
there's this this is almost like
tradition in the modern military now
that when you leave you post like your
favorite pictures of your career
and then a post um and you acknowledge
the lads and then
and then you post it out and i was
writing my post and i was picking the
photos
and i was blubbing i was just like
crying on the floor but to myself and
i'd kept it in for so long i didn't
think i was going to do this and then i
was just in utter tears
because it was this just this excitement
that i was going onto this new phase of
my life but also that's it now
i'm never going to do that again and
that made me who i am today
i lied on the floor and i think part of
the tears was
i'm never going to go mountain training
again i'm never going to go
out to the states and go in the mojave
desert again i'm never i'm never going
to go to afghan again i know
it's difficult as it was it's an
adventure and then
crying crying crying and my wife kicked
my foot which she's actually literally
hoovering next to me
she's like you're going to get up but i
was like
oh we had this little moment together
and i kind of like gave it all on the
plate
and then i went and booked marathon to
sarbs yeah of course you did
because i thought i've got to have
something i've got to have a challenge
which will uh fulfill that
so now you're running this business
looping what is lupin doing
you i'm guessing you've really felt the
pain of running a business and
starting a business because it's a
startup right during the pandemic what
is lupine doing and how's that process
been
so what will help me explain lupin even
more is probably stepping back into the
marines for the first time when i put my
hand up and said
i don't think i'm that well at the
moment i think there's something that
might be wrong
i'm bottling it up for so long you know
come back from operations
keeping it all inside guilt you know two
ieds which went off behind me
injured people and you carry that with
you
and so you feel like you can't talk out
and there's a stigma of don't talk
just keep walking forward and i remember
that moment of
thinking everyone around me looks really
strong and tough and they just seem to
be shrugging it off they're like yeah we
did after i'm crack on come on then
that's
and i'm inside i'm like ah i don't feel
too good at the moment
and it things happen and as i said i got
in trouble
and things didn't go to plan and then
finally i put my hand up
to one of the lads and said i think i've
got issues here
and he went yeah same here i have as
well what you've been seeing and what
you've been hearing and it was like
whoa just instantly like you're not
you're not alone and you feel this as
well and like having this big
conversation
a couple of beers doesn't always help
but a couple of beers for us at that
moment was like
are you do you feel weak and all these
things and um
that forever has stuck with me you know
marines
one of our values is integrity and
integrity means to be able to go
i don't feel too good today it doesn't
mean you don't go into your job but if
you have an awareness of how i'm feeling
you know maybe you can back me a bit
more
or you can help me a bit more and that's
going to come back i'll help you out
which was where it began with how can we
show it better
and that's all it was was let's make
lupin
something that just asks someone in the
morning how they are
they respond on the platform they
already use so slack teams integration
it records that data pushes it through
to the dashboard
you then log into your dashboard you see
your graph of how you've been recently
compared to last week as well and then
you get to see the close people within
your team as well not the organization
you can see every team in the
organization if you want to but you only
get to see the people within your team
and even within our own workforce and
also
with our alpha and beta testing people
are reaching out to other people because
they see their amber
and it's i did one this morning one of
our teams amber
straight on the phone you're right yeah
i just had a long night with the kids
last night i'm okay i just need a coffee
but all she wanted was that question of
all good yeah and it's yeah i'm okay
and then on the odd occasion we get no
i'm not feeling too good today
take today off them and that person is
going to be more productive next week
we can't bend over for it we know that
in the business world people have to be
in stress states we have to be under
high pressure other times we don't
but it's how more transparent can we be
and i think what the pandemic's actually
showing us is
we can embrace this sounds amazing and
i even know someone ran an organization
with many hundreds of people
um being able to see sort of an early
warning sign yeah for situations
developing
call it the pulse is that what you call
it yeah it would have been super
super valuable you think about it from a
business perspective you stand a chance
of losing good people
because you weren't aware that they were
potentially on a bit of a downward
spiral in terms of morale yeah
and uh losing good people cost you a ton
of money
sounds amazing and it sounds like a very
long way from afghanistan
do you know what i mean going into tech
because tech is a beast in itself it's a
whole nother
i've worked in tech in san francisco and
stuff and it's a whole nother language
and
culture and philosophy and stuff so to
go from
you know your early years to to bouncer
to
afghanistan to you know helping the
england team to now working in tech is
one hell of a journey in a short
amount of time so incredibly impressive
you've lived many lives
in your in the one that you've
experienced and i actually was thinking
as you're telling the stories today
how honored i am that someone like you
listens to my podcast i was like i think
i need to listen to your [ __ ] podcast
you're i hit a low moment last year when
we dropped investment
and we took these overheads like we went
from like
what was it three so about six grand a
month overhead
to suddenly thousands and thousands of
pounds because we've got a team in an
office
and we're looking at our reserves going
outside two months worth then we got
four months
and we were getting no after no
afternoon because everyone just shut up
didn't they no one wanted to invest
because
protecting your money and i listened to
yours and
dan murray certains to just take
inspiration
i don't know this world well enough and
you guys do and i was listening to it
going
done it they've done it they can do it i
can do it right okay
and low [ __ ] moments crying into my
wife's arms going
why have i done this i've put the house
at risk kids at risk this is [ __ ]
it's better to be worth it but i want to
make it happen i want to see
a change out there i want to see a
change in business i want to see your
businesses be more open
it's not about raising the money it's
about fighting to raise that money so i
can make that happen
and we raised the money seven days
before missing payroll
we raised half a million just over half
a million and it's listening to your
stories
it's listening to others was the moment
for me where i'm like just keep
going just i listened to the ones this
morning i was thinking about this
struggle that you guys were talking
about and i was like
sometimes struggle's good yeah it gets
you to dig deep and sits in the trenches
and i've been in the trenches
and we've now been through the trenches
and yeah it's inspiring you know when i
got the
nod last week i was like huh
that's a massive compliment i i think i
you know i've learned a ton from
speaking to you today
um i know you produce content yourself
you've got your book which is awesome
um so i just wanted to say thank you
because it's been one hell of a
conversation and i think this when i
reflect
on it this is really the reason why i
started this podcast was to hear these
stories
and and the just the diversity in
struggle and overcoming and persisting
and purpose and
reinventing yourself is the reason this
podcast exists and you exemplify all of
that so
thank you so much for your time today
ben and you you know you said it was a
um a high moment for you to come on this
podcast but i feel that
um going the opposite way and i really
really mean that i really mean that
because you're an incredibly impressive
guy thank you
people ask me for book recommendations
all the time and i finally got one for
you
it's a book called happy sexy
millionaire
which is authored by me um i spent the
last
almost two years in jungles around the
world in costa rica and indonesia
in solitude writing this book it's the
most
important thing i've ever created and
there's this crazy thing when you write
a book because
you spend so much time pouring your
heart and soul into it and everything
you know and all of the revelations
you've had in your life
and then there's this barrier which is
that people have to buy the thing
in order for them to get that thing that
means so much to you i wish that wasn't
the case
it's just the way the industry is and in
order to get that distribution and to
get it on shelves you need a publisher
so
please please please if you can if
you've ever liked anything i've
ever produced this podcast my instagrams
anything i've ever said
read this book there was no ghost writer
i wrote every single word myself there's
some real surprises in there
it's an honest sometimes hilarious
incredibly vulnerable
hopefully valuable recount of my life my
journey
everything i've learned across across
the way and really the answer to being
fulfilled to being happy and to
achieving success
it is the most important important thing
i've ever created so i implore you to go
to amazon now or wherever you get your
books
and get that pre-order and everybody
that pre-orders the book because
pre-orders in this crazy publishing
industry
count as way more than just a normal
sale if you get that pre-order
i'm gonna put you into a group with
everybody that's pre-ordered it and i'm
gonna send you some exclusive stuff so
the first things i'm gonna do is a
series of voice notes which i think are
um
are gonna be pretty powerful i'm gonna
give you access to some tickets which
nobody else will have
and i'm gonna do everything i can to
thank you for for giving me that sort of
nine quid of your money or whatever it
is
happy sexy millionaire you can pre-order
it everywhere now and if you do get that
pre-order
please do dm me because i'd love to
thank you myself
[Music]